zombies will return for black ops cold
war cyberpunk is in final month crunch
and spider-man miles morales saves can
be transferred
i'm chastity here with the biggest
gaming news of the day let's jump in
call of duty black ops cold war is
bringing back zombies mode and here's
what you need to know
activision says this version is
something of a reboot the story is
starting fresh but it will include
characters and easter eggs from the
previous zombie modes
gregory weaver from the first black ops
leads a team called requiem as they
explore a world war ii bunker which is
similar to the original zombies map from
world at war
all weapons are said to be viable while
playing the new zombies even ones that
previously tended to get weaker in later
rounds
but if you need to get out there's a new
x-fill option this will cause a large
number of zombies to swarm you but
there's a reward if you can reach the
chopper and escape
zombies will be both crossplay and cross
gen the same battle pass from warzone
and regular multiplayer will also
include
zombies cold war comes to ps4 ps5
xbox one series x series s and pc on
november 13th
with cyberpunk 2077 coming soon cd
projekt red has entered a mandatory
crunch period to get it done
to meet its november deadline cyberpunk
devs are now working six day work weeks
to finish the game
crunch is an unhealthy practice that has
received scrutiny in recent years
but studio head adam badowski has
released a statement trying to justify
it in this case
these last six weeks are our final
sprint on a project we've all spent much
of our lives on
something we care for deeply the
majority of the team understands that
push
especially in light of the fact that
we've just sent the game to cert and
every day brings us visibly closer to
shipping a game we want to be proud of
this is one of the hardest decisions
i've had to make but everyone is well
compensated for every extra hour they
put in
and like in recent years 10 percent of
the annual profit our company generates
in 2020 will be split directly among the
team
regardless of how the team is being
compensated cd projekt red has been
criticized for taking this route
especially since the studio previously
said it would not crunch and was
committing to establishing a healthy
work balance
there's been some confusion on which
game saves will transfer from ps4 to ps5
but now we have clarity on at least one
title
if you play spider-man miles morales on
ps4 those saves will be able to transfer
to ps5
you can also upgrade to the ps5 version
on the standalone game for free
however save data from the regular
spider-man will not transfer
this is because spider-man remastered is
only coming to ps5
as an add-on for miles morales it's
included in the ultimate edition
or you can buy it as a 20 dlc and since
the ultimate edition is only 20
more you won't be spending any extra if
you buy spider-man remastered later
and if you play the remaster you'll
notice that peter parker will look
different
that's because insomniac has a new face
model for the character replacing john
bobniak with ben jordan
this is actually due to the facial
capture of yuri lowenthal who voices
peter parker because
ben jordan's face is a better match
spider-man remastered and miles morales
are both out alongside ps5's launch on
november 12th
and finally just a heads up that
nintendo is revealing the next dlc
fighter for smash ultimate tomorrow at 7
a.m pacific time 10 a.m eastern
who do you hope it will be i'll put my
support behind gino let me know who you
want in the comments below
and that's your save state for wednesday
i'm chasity and you can find me on
twitter at chastity underscore v come
back tomorrow for more news and i'll see
you next time
you